[Music]
on this tuesday night
ontario ends inoculation interruptions
the apologies for a holiday break we
will not take any more days off
until we win this war against cloven 19.
plus the proposal to do what no one else
is doing
desperate families and demands for
better care
save our seniors now pleased to protect
our most
vulnerable from the virus boeing 737 max
returns to american airspace
the families who want to see the fleet
grounded for good
and major earthquake
chaos in croatia
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening
i hope you and your family are doing
well tonight with new year's eve just a
couple days away there's a stark
reminder
not to let your guard down with covid19
canada's two largest provinces are now
battling the virus
like never before ontario reported a
staggering
2553 cases a single day high
quebec also marked a new record with
2381 infections
and the province has confirmed its first
case of the more contagious variant of
covet 19
the fourth province to do so behind
ontario
alberta and bc pressure is growing to
get canadians vaccinated as soon as
possible
after several provinces like ontario
were criticized for
scaling back immunizations over the
holidays
clinics in all provinces are now open
and ontario expects to get
its first doses of the moderna vaccine
tomorrow
but as richard zusman reports there's
still lots of work to do
holiday break over after days of being
criticized for closing covet 19 vaccine
clinics in ontario
the person in charge of distribution
apologizing
was the wrong decision i think i
acknowledge that quite clearly and
accept a responsibility that we'll get
better
faster now because we've learned from
that and we've heard the voices of the
people of ontario saying get on with
this
former general rick hillier announcing
ontario will now be fast tracking covert
vaccinations
and asking the federal government to
consider providing the moderna vaccine
as a single dose instead of two
something not done in any other
jurisdiction in the world
i haven't seen evidence that says one
shot can work what i'd like is
some somebody to look at it look at it
come back and tell us no it's not
possible
or come back and say yes we can do it
and here's what we're going to do
the federal government says moderna
would need to prove the one shot is
effective in order to support a change
it currently requires two doses
administered 28 days apart
the moderna vaccine is now being
distributed in canada
arriving in the northwest territories
and yukon on monday
vaccinations set to begin there in
january you can start building that
asking health canada asking mederna
what's the longest interval we can go
between the two doses
i think we can certainly consider when
that second note
needs to be if it's day 28 for mederna
or can we wait
you know six weeks or eight weeks across
the country doses are slow to roll out
every jurisdiction with fewer than 10
000 shots except ontario and quebec
many regions running reduced
immunization clinic hours over the past
week
including manitoba british columbia and
ontario compare canada with a
vaccination rate of 0.16 per 100 people
to the united states where four times as
many people
are getting the shot per capita with a
rate of 0.64 per 100 people being
vaccinated
so the term falling behind is laden with
all sorts of emotions i think what i
would say
is we could definitely be doing better
every province and territory has
different priorities in terms of who's
getting the shot
first but the common goal is to give the
vaccination to those that are most
vulnerable
before the general public the stated
goal from the federal government still
to inoculate
everyone in canada who wants it by the
fall of 2021
richard's lisbon global news victoria
while health officials urged people to
stay home for the holidays
ontario's finance minister didn't rod
phillips and his wife left canada on
vacation on december 13th
it's not clear where he is or when he's
coming back
he said the getaway was previously
planned adding
if he knew the province would eventually
shut down he would have canceled the
trip
the federal government tweeted a
reminder today advising against
non-essential travel
noting there are severe penalties for
returning travelers who don't abide
by the mandatory 14-day quarantine
phillips says he will
but ontario's premier says he wants
phillips back in canada now
tonight doug ford says he's extremely
disappointed in phillips and calls the
trip
unacceptable once again
in this second wave our elderly are
dealing with this dangerous outbreak at
long-term care homes
all over canada in ontario at one home
the death toll keeps climbing at least
48
people have died friends and family
gathered outside there today
morgan campbell has been following the
latest developments morgan what's their
message
we are talking about dozens of deaths
during the christmas break
alone it has caused family members and
advocacy groups to
call for government accountability and
military
intervention it is intervention that
they want to see
right now
you are looking at more than 40 candles
to honor those taken by covet 19
at this long-term care home east of
toronto
you can see the fear and anguish in the
eyes
of those protesting outside of tender
care living center
as the number of coveted positive
residents continues to mount
my greatest fear is that my grandmother
is going to die without dignity and
she's left alone and scared and
feeling like we weren't there for her
jessica wong's grandmother is one of
more than
100 residents diagnosed with the novel
coronavirus so has brenda tam's mother
moon she cringes every time tender care
shows up on her caller id i'm scared
they tell you like
your mom getting worse or
something bad news north york general
hospital took over the management of the
outbreak
on christmas day the home continues to
maintain
infection prevention and control
education
is well underway during a news
conference at queen's park
our request for information went
unanswered thanks everyone
the ford government has received
backlash from
families and advocacy groups for not
addressing the deaths
during the holiday season we've lost our
priorities at this point of the game
this is not acceptable
although grimm there is a silver lining
families say they are finding strength
in numbers as they forge through these
uncertain times you know being there for
each other and empowering each other
there are concerns that basic care needs
are not being met but family members
have been shut out of the home and are
unable to verify
meanwhile the home is conducting a
hiring blitz in an effort to
replenish a depleting staffing level
morgan campbell
global news to the u.s now which has
recorded its first case at the new
coronavirus variant
the country's vaccine rollout is also
hitting some
major snags the trump administration had
promised
20 million americans would be vaccinated
by the end of the year
but only 2 million people have rolled up
their sleeves
as jackson proskow reports incoming
president joe biden faces
a monumental task to get the job done
let's do it despite more high profile
vaccinations
like vice president-elect kamala harris
sired
everyone when it is your turn
get vaccinated the u.s has so far
failed to deliver on promises of
widespread rapid vaccine roll
out a problem president-elect joe biden
is set to inherit in less than a month
the trump administration's plan to
distribute vaccines is falling
behind far behind biden has promised to
deliver 100 million doses in his first
100 days in office
and vowed to use the defense production
act to ramp up vaccine production
i'm going to move heaven and earth to
get us going in the right direction
just a few weeks ago the trump
administration made its own big promises
20 million americans could be vaccinated
just before the end of this month in
december to date
little more than 2 million americans
have been vaccinated
even though more than 11 million doses
have been sent to various locations
around the country
shots simply aren't going into arms fast
enough
once they made these arrangements and
deals with the manufacturers they
basically
kind of did a little bit of a hands-off
approach in terms of how
then states would choose to prioritize
people
distribute the vaccines and honestly
deal with problems
experts say the u.s needs to turn the
current rate of one million
vaccinations per week into three and a
half million vaccinations per day to
reach herd immunity by the summer
i'm worried about over promising on when
things are going to be able to be
back to normal the you have to build in
that there are going to be hitches in
this process
still a vaccine will eventually deliver
a way forward
even if delivering the vaccine takes
longer than expected
jackson prosko global news washington
back in the u.s after a ban coming up
the push to stop the boeing 737
max from flying here in canada
canadian senator elaine mccoy has passed
away at 74 years old
her start in politics began in alberta
the mccoy was born in brandon manitoba
a lawyer who once served as a calgary
mla
the former alberta cabinet minister was
named to the senate in 2005.
she served as an independent voice for
canadians and
was the first senator to blog about her
experiences in ottawa
boeing's troubled 737 max 8 is back in
the air resuming passenger flights in
the united states
the aircraft was grounded worldwide that
was following two deadly crashes that
killed a total of
346 people including
18 canadians as ross lord reports canada
could soon follow suit
despite the objections of victims
families
reintroducing the 737 max to the flying
public could be difficult
after all the pandemic has stifled air
travel and polling suggests people are
extra nervous about flying in this plane
it's no wonder before the 737 max was
grounded
it was involved in a pair of crashes
that killed
346 people but boeing and its airline
partners
insist the plane is now safe to fly
fortunately
this aircraft has been checked out from
top to bottom
and we're confident that it's it's ready
to go a statement from boeing says
the company has learned many hard
lessons from the mass casualty crashes
lessons that further focused our
attention on our core values
of safety quality and integrity there's
no mention of another priority
profit a congressional committee said
boeing put cost cutting ahead of safety
updates to flight control software that
was flawed
software linked to both fatal crashes
while the aircraft has been down for
20 months they've actually gone through
and and put out a number of different
air within its directive so
the wire bundle separation is actual
physical uh changes that's been done to
the
wire bundle uh inside of the aircraft
itself 24 year old danielle moore was
one of 18 canadians
killed in the ethiopian airlines crash
her father
like most of the victims families
opposes the plane's return
well the best possible outcome i think
is for
for boeing to come to their senses and
say you know what we can't we can't
continue with a charade
we're going to pull the plug on the the
max it's not going to happen
the max is still grounded in canada
though just this month
transport canada approved design changes
to the aircraft
bringing it one step closer to flying
again in canadian skies
ross lord global news
ahead the desperate search for survivors
in croatia after a second
powerful earthquake
a second powerful earthquake in two days
has rattled croatia
the magnitude 6.4 earthquake killed at
least seven people
and left a trail of destruction
southeast of zagreb
a desperate search is underway now for
survivors
now back to covet 19. in the united
kingdom where case numbers are surging
the second round of pfizer biontech
vaccinations
is now officially underway but as
redmond shannon reports
many countries are nowhere near that
ireland's first covet 19 shot
the latest european union country to
begin a vaccination program
the eu is playing catch-up with its
departing member
the uk where vaccinations began three
weeks ago
worldwide the us is way out in front
with more than two million doses
administered
canada is in fifth place with just under
sixty thousand shots
but per capita israel is streets ahead
of
everyone else with more than 5 of the
population vaccinated
israel's early success in quickly
hitting half a million
is perfect timing for prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
as he prepares for yet another election
he called israel the world champion of
vaccinations
coming after a year that has hit the
country's economy
hard we have a secret weapon we're a
small
country professor jonathan gershone says
israel's efficient healthcare network
helps too
but he highlights an issue that many
countries will soon face
i'm a bit worried about where we're
going to be
once we've exhausted the enthusiastic
sector
of our population and we start to have
to systematically
convince those that are vaccine hesitant
israel of course is relatively rich but
poorer nations will struggle to manage
vaccines that need to be stored at minus
70 degrees that's where the astrazeneca
vaccine could make a difference
reportedly ready for uk approval this
week
it's really been developed in order to
be able to produce a vaccine
as a very low cost that can be rolled
out worldwide
countries like iran meanwhile face a
different challenge
it has begun early trials of its own
vaccine its hand partly forced
by u.s trade sanctions redmond shannon
global news
london next how
science stepped up in 2020 to face a
global threat
edmonton soccer star alfonso davies has
been named the canadian press
male athlete of the year davies who was
born in a refugee camp in ghana had an
outstanding year
winning the uefa champions league at the
age of 19.
at this time last year doctors in china
were treating
dozens of patients with an unknown
pneumonia
it's hard to fathom that covid19 was
first named in the same year a vaccine
was developed for the deadly virus
eric sorenson explains how the pandemic
paved the way for historic breakthroughs
in medical science
when chinese television announced the
first death from an unknown virus last
january the seafood market in wuhan was
already
shut down critics say authorities were
not transparent
as patient numbers grew but at that very
moment
chinese researchers shared online with
the world
something they just discovered the
genetic sequence of the virus
immediately an army of scientists across
the globe put aside other work
and zeroed in on this one virus
the sharing of expertise and experiences
from china is very important
so the genetic sequence was critical in
all of this
it allowed us to identify the nature of
the virus very very quickly so we knew
it was a coronavirus with this novel
coronavirus genetically understood
some scientists used snippets of
messenger rna
to tell cells to build spike proteins
like the ones on the virus itself
the vaccine was tested on volunteers
infecting them with the proteins
that triggered the immune system to
create antibodies and t
cells to attack them and the immune
response would
then be ready to pounce when the real
virus shows up
it was simple and experts believed safe
we never touch the virus we make the
protein
we can make it very pure and we can
inject that and have an immune response
to the spike protein
that will be protective by spring the
virus was now spreading far beyond china
described in europe as the worst health
crisis in a century
then north america was hit we are now
the epicenter of this crisis
in canada covert 19 arrived unseen and
deadly
the country locked down we all need to
act
now covet 19 is a serious public health
threat
quietly though in nondescript buildings
around the world from beijing to new
york
in spotless laboratories in india and in
germany
various vaccines were being developed an
international effort more cooperative
than competitive
all the vaccine manufacturers are
working together
and we're all in a race to battle the
disease
you know there's no one-upmanship here
labs worked flat out
money was no object because governments
put up whatever was needed
we have collectively pledged 7.4
billion euros for vaccines diagnostics
and treatments advancements were
happening with unprecedented speed
because so many people were available
for vaccine trials
and so many tested positive the duration
of the trial is determined by how
quickly
you can get people testing positive for
the disease
so this compressed what would have been
years of data collection
in two weeks it changed everything by
summer covet 19 appeared to be easing up
and the vaccine still seemed very far
away but the canadian government was
securing doses by the millions
from pfizer moderna johnson and johnson
and others
contracts for more vaccines per capita
than any country in the world
we're making sure that if one of these
potential vaccines
is successful canada and canadians
will have access to the doses they need
the importance of those decisions would
become apparent later
as a new wave of covet 19 swept in with
the autumn weather
our world has reached an agonizing
milestone
the loss of one million lives from the
coveted 19 pandemic
covered cases and hospitalizations
surged and lockdowns returned
but the swiftness of the science the
funding
the trials the vaccine production and
the global partnerships
were all about to pay off we have a
vaccine for the world
more than one manufacturer delivered
startling results
it is a great day for science it is a
great
day for humanity when you realize that
your vaccine has a 90 percent
effectiveness
that's overwhelming like a december gift
the first approved vaccines
from pfizer biontec were delivered and
canadians were among the first in the
world to start getting shots
a turning point in a terrible year it's
going to give us back
our families our communities our lives
our loved ones
and it's going to save people that we
would otherwise have lost
vaccine development typically takes four
years and in many cases much longer
kovit 19 took less than one year the
speed is the result
of a singular focus of the entirety of
civilization on one problem
so i can't imagine this happening at any
other point
in prior human history for a number of
technological and global cooperation
reasons
this is one of the most magical moments
in public health history
canada's large contracts not only bode
well for vaccinating canadians
the world health organization singled
out this country for its commitment to
share
millions of excess doses through kovacs
so developing countries will not be left
out
i would like to thank canada and prime
minister trudeau
for committing to share surplus those of
kovid19
vaccines immunizations will take time
and the virus will still make this
winter dispiriting and deadly
but one crowning accomplishment will
come from 2020
vaccines enough for the world have begun
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that's global national for this
tuesday night i'm farah nasser
tonight your canada is the sunrise over
calgary
thank you so much for watching until
tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other have a great night
[Music]
you